em bị dài mất 5 phút hơn 20 phút đang thì là phần em đang mong muốn nghe nhận xét thầy vì là
em đã cố gắng phân bổ là tập trung vào 3 phần là nói về mô hình nói về kết quả với cả phân tích
về payload thì đều chia ra là khoảng 5 đến 6 phút em đang chưa biết là sẽ phải loại phần nào thì
thì kể nếu mà có nói nó lưu loát hơn thì cũng không thể hạ thấp xuống dưới 15 phút được
Nó muốn hỏi qua ý kiến của thầy
Dạ em thưa thầy là trước đây em cũng có thuyết trình ạ
thì là bộ đo thứ 4 của 4 chỉ số cơ bản ạ
thì là khi đưa lên thực tế thì nó không thể hiện nhiều ạ
bởi vì là hầu hết các mô hình đều nhận biết được đâu là dữ liệu tấn công đâu là dữ liệu thường ạ
Mà cái quan trọng nhất là khi mà nhìn vào thực tế
Thì nó có thể hiện được
Nó có thể hiện được
Em đưa thầy có phải thầy gọi cho em không ạ thầy